Bonjour, je
suis candidat pour la majorité présidentielle.
Est-ce que vous saviez qu'il y avait des élections ?
Merci maman. Bon, merci à vous, merci.
J'suis venue à Marseille
pour dire aux Marseillais que l'Europe avait
besoin de Marseille,
et aussi pour venir voir concrètement comment l'Europe
accompagne la vie des Marseillais.
Alors la visite du port ce matin a été la parfaite
illustration à la fois de l'engagement dans la
transition mondiale mental
et de comment on on reprend la main
sur notre souveraineté et sur notre puissance.
Très clairement, ça veut dire, euh.
Comment on sort du coup pétrole,
comment on sort de ces dépendances-là. Et on a vu, euh.
Très concrètement l'illustration avec l'électification,
euh. Nord de Marseille,
euh. Le développement de l'hydrogène,
ce porte qui est 1 interconnexion majeure pour
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne.